los norteamericanos han ido dando
mayores detalles sobre esa exclusión que
se sintió hoy en kabul en las cercanías
del aeropuerto hamid karzai sería un
misil disparado desde un drone a un
automóvil que transportaba a varios
hombres cargados de explosivos y en las
últimas horas los norteamericanos
especialmente el presidente joe biden
había advertido de la amenaza de un
nuevo ataque terrorista llegado del
estado islámico de khorasan como el que
ya había sucedido el jueves pasado que
dejó más de 170 fallecidos este misil
cuando habría impactado el automóvil
habría hecho una segunda explosión luego
como consecuencia de los explosivos que
cargaban estos hombres entonces no se ha
asegurado que hayan habido víctimas ni
civiles ni militares en este en este
atentado pero también hay bastantes
dudas en kabul de lo que sobre lo que
sucedió esta tarde porque se dio otra
explosión esta habría venido de un
cohete en una vivienda también en la
parte norte del aeropuerto aunque nadie
ha podido identificar si
hasta que sus exclusiones están
relacionadas en este último ataque
tampoco habrían habido víctimas civiles
sin embargo estamos en las últimas horas
de ya la retirada de las tropas
norteamericanas que hablaban de que mil
personas quedaba vídeo y dentro del
aeropuerto que se estaban evacuando
están las últimas personas civiles